Yo, God lo.
>> What's up, man? You a Muslim?
>> Damn. You're not a Muslim, man.
Alhamdulillah, man.
>> All right. Where does Jesus mention you
Muhammad, my friend?
>> You a caffir?
>> Say that again.
>> I said you a caffir.
>> What's that,
>> bro? You a caffer? Yes or no?
>> What is that?
>> A disbeliever.
>> Oh, no. I'm not a caffer.
>> You're not a caffir?
>> No, you
Islam.
>> Okay.
>> Don't smile. It don't look good on you,
man.
>> I think it looks good on you. I I Hold
on, sweetheart. Does my smile look good
on me? Oh, my wife thinks my my smile
looks good on me.
>> You look like a Trust me, your
wife your wife's cheating on you,
>> sweetheart. Are you cheating on me?
>> Oh, she said she's not cheating on me,
bro. What are you talking about?
>> Trust me, she is.
>> Trust me.
>> I'll bring you the I'll bring you the
evidence. I want to bring Trust you,
bro. Is that what you want me to do?
Trust you, bro.
>> But listen, listen, listen. Let's get
into this. What's
>> He says he has evidence that you're
cheating on me. What's up with that?
>> She [clears throat] said you're smoking
what Muhammad used to smoke. Is that
true? Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam never used to smoke.
>> He said Muhammad
>> say peace be upon him. Don't just say
his name in vain.
>> All right, my bad. He He said He said
Muhammad peace be upon him. Never used
to smoke.
>> You have three gods that truth.
>> Can you not laugh, sweetheart? That's
rude. I'm sorry. I have to mute my wife.
She's cursing the prophet by laughing at
this. I have no idea why she's laughing.
>> But listen, bro. Um I trust you, bro.
And I trust you with my life. I trust
that you have my best intentions. One
second. One second. I'm talking. I trust
that you have my best interest at heart.
And [clears throat] um you know, maybe
we can team up against against uh
Christina. You know, I've I've honestly
thought that she was undercover anyway.
You know, she's still in my fans. Um
going on shows, destroying Muslims. I
think that she cheated in our last
Muslim debate.
>> A whole load of crap, man.
>> I know, but I think I think they I think
she cheated. So,
>> bro, listen listen.
>> Like, how is it possible? How is it
possible that she knew the hadith off
her off off the head? You know,
>> I heard that you were saying is did
Jesus mention prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasall
>> Yeah. Did he do it?
>> Yes. In the Quran there is a revelation
from Allah subhana wa tala stating that
Jesus did mention prophet Muhammad
>> I know. So so the the question is where
did he mention it? Cuz the Quran is
saying one thing. I want to see proof of
of what Allah is saying supposedly.
>> Cool.
>> So where where do we find Jesus saying
this?
>> Let me give you the chapter. Let me give
you the chapter.
>> I don't I don't think you understand
what I'm asking. I'm not asking for a
Quran verse.
>> So, what do you want? Do you want your
your what's that Bible?
>> I want to know where Jesus said this.
So, I know the Quran in chapter 616 says
Jesus said this. I want to know where he
said it. I want to see him actually
saying it, not the Quran saying he said
it.
>> What do you mean you want What do you
mean you want to see him saying it? What
do you mean?
>> So, for example, you agree that Jesus
lived before the Quran, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So this means that the Quran is
recounting something that already
happened. So it already happened that
Jesus supposedly mentioned Muhammad to
come after him. This is recorded
somewhere, right?
>> 100%.
>> Okay. So I want to know where that's
recorded because the Quran is just
recounting something that already
happened. I want to see when it
originally happened.
>> Can I ask you a question now? Who who
was the Quran who was the Quran revealed
to?
>> I don't think it was revealed to anyone.
It was revealed to the prophet Muhammad.
It just gives it gives [clears throat]
accounts of Jesus but it does not go
into detail.
>> But it gave it went into detail right
here. It went into detail saying that
Jesus specifically said Ahmed will come
after him. So I want to see where Jesus
said that.
>> As you said, you want to see the proper
proof.
>> Yes.
>> From my own knowledge, I can't provide
that. So Allah, I can't provide that.
>> Okay. That that's fair. I I I hear you.
Thank you for being honest. So and it's
not just you, brother. It's not just you
that that can't provide this. No Muslim
can provide this information for me. And
I'm a Christian. Say that.
>> I can't say that. I can't. I've seen
you. I've never I I can I can say I can
say with a confidence. Hold on my
brother. Hold on my brother.
>> I can I can My brother, can you not
speak when I'm speaking? Please.
>> Let's have a respectful conversation.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Cuz I I like your honesty. You are
honest and humble saying that you know
you can't provide the information right
now. There's no shame in that. I have
spoken to thousands of Muslims. I have
seen the best of Muslims engage with
this topic. Not one is able to produce
this evidence that the Quran's claiming
that Jesus mentioned Muhammad. Okay? Or
mentioned Ahmed. So with this being
said, as a Christian, the words of Jesus
are the most important to me. The most
important. If Jesus [clears throat]
never said this, then this would mean
that the Quran is making a false claim.
Would you agree with that? The Quran can
never be false.
>> But if Jesus if Jesus never said this,
then the Quran would be false, right?
>> But but what what Bible are you reading
though?
>> Any other Bibles?
>> Any other Bible?
>> Mhm.
>> Now the New Testament, I don't I don't
believe that there's the proper inj
>> Oh [screaming]
snap.
OH SNAP. And we go again.
[screaming]
What's going on, ladies and gentlemen? I
am your host, God Logic. Hold on one
second, my my contestant. I'm your host,
God Logic, and we have another
contestant to try out our favorite
segment. Please mute up, my brother.
Just hold on a second. You'll have your
chance. Don't interrupt this part. We
have a contestant who is willing to
challenge and step up to the plate in
our favorite segment on what's the NGO.
He says we don't have it. What we have
is not the angel. That means he knows
what it is. So live yours. Tell us what
is the in
knowledge proper knowledge on it. I'm
not I'm not I'm not a proper talker. a
view. But from my own knowledge, like
from what I dabbled on, it just told me
that it's a gospel. It's a gospel that
that's a revelation from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to Jesus who is a prophet, not
a god.
>> So before we can even get into the
nitty-gritty, not something that's
written not something that's written by
Luke, John, and and I got you. I got
you, brother. I got you
specifically from Allahh.
>> I got you. I got you. So, be
>> before we can even get into the
nitty-gritty, you already started off by
saying you don't have knowledge on this.
>> 100%.
>> 100%. I don't have
>> So, so you don't have Now, let me just
make sure. You don't have You 100% do
not have knowledge about this. Yet, Yet
you have a Yet you're able to tell me.
Yet, you're able to tell me. You know,
that's
>> my brother. I'm going to ask you again
to stop interrupting me while I'm
talking. Is that Can you do that?
>> Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool talk.
>> I appreciate it. So, you said that you
are 100% not knowledgeable on this
issue. Yet, you're able to tell me what
the angil is not when you have 100% no
knowledge on the subject.
>> What? Bro, I have some knowledge but not
a full knowledge. As I said,
>> you said 100%.
>> Full full knowledge. I do not have full
knowledge. What is that?
>> You said that you do that you 100% do
not have knowledge on the issue and yet
you're saying that you could tell me
what the angel isn't. Now
>> listen me I can just like from what you
say like I can see you talk so there's
so much contradictions in what you say.
>> So much contradictions what I say.
>> Yeah. And like I don't I don't have
knowledge like that. But I see videos I
see videos of you getting cooked. You
know we're seasoning. You know we're
seasoning. You're getting cooked like
like like boiled eggs. You're getting
cooked.
>> Just one second, my brother. One second.
Let me write down what you said cuz I
got I got I got to write down the
stupidity of what you said. So
>> brother
one second. Please don't come off mute.
Just one second. One second. You got a
lot of background noise. One second.
Stop coming off mute, please. All right.
So 44 minutes. We got the What's the NGO
segment? What's the NGO segment? And our
contestant here says that he has 100% no
knowledge on the subject.
>> I did not say that. I did not say that.
I did not say that. That's the thing
with you. You like changing things up.
Your brain is something else, mate. I
said I do not I [clears throat] said I
do not have full knowledge.
>> I have 100% no knowledge.
>> Brother, I don't know if you're you're
deaf. [laughter] I don't know if you're
deaf or mute. But mate, I did not say no
knowledge. I said I do not have 100%
knowledge on that full knowledge. I do
not have full knowledge and that is
complete and thorough understanding on
that topic itself. Did you hear that?
Good logic or no logic? No logic.
>> All right. I want to show you something.
>> Listen. Listen. I'm asking you a
question. Did you hear that? No lo no
logic. I
>> I want to show you something. Okay. I
need I need you I need you to I need you
to mute your mic. I need you to mute
your mic. Answer my question. Shut your
mic up. I want to show you something. I
want to show you that we're going to
make you famous today. We're going to
make you famous today. Watch this.
>> Thank you.
>> Please meet up cuz you got too much
background noise. You got too much
happening at the cabba at your house.
>> I'm going to show you something. I want
you to tell me if this is you.
>> I got a family. I got a family on you,
man.
>> I got you.
>> I want you Go ahead and mute up. Go
ahead and mute up. We don't need your
pagan mouth to speak. Mute your dumb
mouth. Matter of fact, that's enough of
you. You You get off the stage. You're
too dumb to be on the stage with me.
You're too much of an idiot to be on the
stage. You've already exposed yourself
and contradicted yourself. But I just
want to know if this is you. Okay. We we
like to bring receipts. Let's see if
this is you real quick. Let's see. Uh
let's go about right here. Maybe. Let's
see. Let's unmute this.
>> Understanding on that therefore mute
things up.
>> He has 100 do not have knowledge on the
issue. You said 100%. When you have 100%
you're able to tell meible yet you're by
saying
I double I'm not
and step up to the plate what we have is
not the that means he knows what it is
watch this so live yours tell us what is
the in
I don't have knowledge proper knowledge
on it I'm not I'm not I'm not a proper
talker I'll b Is that you? You don't
have proper knowledge on it. Let's say
that again. Is that you, dummy?
>> I have knowledge. I
don't have knowledge, proper knowledge
on it. I'm not I'm not I'm not a proper
talker. I'll be with you. But from my
own knowledge, like from what I dabbled
on, it just told me that it's a gospel.
It's a gospel that
>> So before we can even get into the
nitty-gritty,
>> not something that's written, not
something that's written by Luke, John,
and and them.
>> I I got you. I got you, brother.
Obviously,
>> it's coming.
>> I have got you. I got you.
>> So,
>> before we can even get into the
nitty-gritty, you already started off by
saying you don't have knowledge on this.
>> 100%.
>> 100%. How How much percent How much
percent was that?
>> 100%.
>> So, so you 100% you don't have knowledge
on the subject. 100% you don't have
knowledge on the subject. But you didn't
say this. This wasn't you, right? This
this maybe maybe Allah made it appear
that you said this, huh? Allah made it
look like you said this. He made it
sound like you said this, but this you
didn't really say this, huh? Let's hear
this again. He started off by saying you
don't have knowledge on this.
>> 100%.
>> So, so you don't don't have you. How
many times you going to say it, brother?
How many times you going to say that you
don't have 100% knowledge on this? That
you 100% don't have knowledge on this?
How many times you gonna say that? How
many times? You said it multiple times.
So, let this be a lesson to the rest of
you. And I I marked it down. You You
made it into the red book. And this is
what I put in the what's the angel
segment. The Muslim said, "I have 100%
no knowledge on the topic, but then
proceeds to tell me what the angel is
not." Then says he never said that he
doesn't have 100% knowledge on the
topic. Then says he didn't say that. I
love you guys, man. You guys, I'm I'm
telling you, it's the arrogant, dumb
ones. You guys are the ones that are the
funnest because with you, I could just
let let go. With the arrogant, dumb,
prideful ones, chopping you down,
cutting you up, busting your lip,
putting my boot on your neck is so fun
to do. It's fun. Now, I would rather I
hope you guys hear me clearly. I would
rather have the honest, humble, uh,
truth-seeking Muslims to speak to. I
would rather have that, but I do I don't
mind destroying, exposing, humiliating
the arrogant, prideful ones. I don't I
could do that one too all day. So, with
that being said, ladies and gentlemen,
Muslims that's going to come up and
engage. This is recorded. We are live.
When you say something, I'm clocking it.
Don't say you didn't say it, cuz I'll
rewind it for you and put it in your
face and embarrass you in front of 3,400
people and 700 people on TikTok. Don't
humiliate yourself by lying and being
arrogant. Come humble, come correct, and
we'll have a nice time. Sounds good.
Sounds good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All
right. So with that being said, that pep
talk being said, I hope that the Muslims
who are going to come up next have
learned from the previous guests. You
learn what not to do. Don't lie to me
cuz I'll humiliate you. Come correct or
else I'll humiliate you. Don't be
disrespectful or else I'll humiliate
you. We'll make you a laughingstock. Me
and my wife will laugh at you, laugh our
guts out at you with the rest of the
chat. Not laughing with you. we will
laugh at you. And if you're a Christian
and you believe that this is a little
too harsh, then this is just isn't for
you. I I suggest you turn this episode
off. But this is what we do here. Dre,
how you doing? You're a Muslim.
>> I trusted you. God logic. I trusted you.
>> How do we reach these kids? All right.
Um Okay. So, let's go ahead and open it
up for the YouTube guests. S, you are on
stage. How you doing?
>> Hey, what's up? Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you. I uh listen, I got
one question, man, if you don't mind.
>> Well, you have to deal with the topic
first. The topic is did Jesus mention
Muhammad? You got to deal with that
first and then you can add.
>> Okay.
>> Uh basically, if you if you ask if uh
Jesus mentions Muhammad, you're
referring to the Bible uh figure. You
want to hear a verse in the Bible,
right?
>> Uh yes.
>> And then if I give a verse, you're going
to say it's not. It's not. And now I'm
going to say, "Yeah, it's Muhammad." So,
>> well, I'm an honest person. If there's a
Bible verse where Jesus mentioned
Muhammad, I have to submit to it. If it
doesn't mention Muhammad, then hopefully
you can be honest and be like, "Okay,
yeah, it doesn't. He didn't say that
here. It doesn't say that here."
>> Okay, sure thing. Uh, listen, uh, think
Deuteronomy 18:18.
>> Okay. In Deuteronomy 18, is that Jesus
speaking?
>> Yeah, he's he mentioning, "I will rise
up for them a prophet like you." So,
so Jesus in Deuteronomy 18 says to Moses
that he Jesus, he says, "I'm going to
raise up for them a prophet like you
>> from among their brothers."
>> Who is he mentioning?
>> So, you're saying that Jesus So Jesus is
the one who raised up Muhammad as a
prophet?
>> That's uh your uh that's what you guys
believe, right? It's not my belief, you
know?
>> No, I don't I don't believe that. Do you
believe that? you. No, but if I'm not
mistaken, you would say Jesus is God and
God and Jesus are the same. And
>> do you agree that Jesus is God?
>> Nah, that's I'm I'm stating what most
Christians believe.
>> I don't care about what Christians
believe. I care about what the text
says.
>> But okay, listen to the first. Okay.
>> No, no, it's So, listen, brother. The
topic is did Jesus mention Muhammad? So,
in answering that, you're going to show
me where Jesus mentioned Muhammad. If
you're if you're going to Deuteronomy
18, then you're saying that Jesus is the
speaker. Is that correct?
>> Wait, say again.
>> You you don't understand what I'm
saying.
>> I uh you you cut a little bit off. I
couldn't catch the last one.
>> So, with me asking where did Jesus
mention Muhammad and you go to
Deuteronomy 18, that means you're saying
that the speaker in Deuteronomy 18 is
Jesus. Is that what you believe?
>> Now, is the question if if I believe
that Jesus is speaking that?
>> Yes. says, "Jesus speaking in
Deuteronomy 18 talking about Muhammad."
>> Okay. Basically, if you're asking me
what I believe, that's what you're doing
right now. I would say the messenger in
this specific verse can be anybody.
>> Who's speaking is my question. Is Jesus
speaking?
>> Jesus gets
>> the one who says, "I will raise up for
them a prophet like you from among their
brothers." Who's saying that?
>> That's God basically.
>> So, is that Jesus speaking?
>> No. No. That's not Jesus for me. Yeah.
That's for you.
>> So if that's not
>> Okay. If that's not Jesus speaking.
>> Not for me. I agree.
>> I need you to take my brother. I need
you to take me to a place where Jesus is
speaking and he mentions Muhammad.
>> Okay. So you're telling me you're
looking for a verse that's mentioning I
am Jesus and I'm bringing a prophet
named Muhammad. That's what you're
looking for basically.
>> No, not verbatim like that. I'm just
looking for wherever Jesus is the
speaker.
>> Yeah.
>> Wherever Jesus is the speaker and he
mentions Ahmed to come after him. That's
what I'm looking for. Like the Quran
says, I'm looking for what the Quran
told me. I he said,
>> "Okay, sure. You're clear. But who who
could it be? If it's not Muhammad,
>> who could who be
>> the first? Who can the first mention?
Who is it referring to?"
>> That's irrelevant because Jesus is the
speaker. No, but
>> what's relevant to my question, my
brother, and hopefully I because I got a
lot of guests waiting and I'm trying to
give you a chance. Please give me take
me to a place where Jesus is a speaker
and he mentions Muhammad. If you don't
have a place, then just say that so we
can move forward.
>> Can I ask you a question now? Uh, logic.
>> Are you okay?
>> Why? Yeah. I'm just asking if I can ask
you a question, you know.
>> And I'm just asking if you're all right.
I'm genuinely
>> course I'm all right. Why not?
>> You sure? You asked me to give you a
verse mentioning Muhammad in the Bible.
I give you one and then you're saying I
want one that Jesus is saying it. You
believe Jesus is God. You
>> get off my stage. Thanks for coming,
man. Muslim, you're on stage.
>> Hello.
>> Yeah. So what?
>> Can you show me where Jesus mentioned
Muhammad?
>> Jesus.
I don't I don't think he mentions
Muhammad.
>> So then the Quran is false then, right?
Cuz it says he did. Quran says where
>> do you see the screen?
>> Oh yeah.
>> So this is chapter 61:6 of the Quran.
And remember Jesus son of Mary said, "Oh
children of Israel, I am I am the
messenger of Allah to you confirming the
law which came before me and glad
tidings of a messenger to come after me
whose name shall be Ahmed." But when he
came to them with clear signs, they
said, "This is evident sorcery." So
what do you mean like uh the Bible
there's uh Muslims say we say that we uh
there was like Ahmed or something
written in the Bible.
>> Yeah. G the Quran says that Jesus
mentioned AIT. I'm just asking where is
that? Where can I find that? Well, I I
searched on Chad GPD and he said uh that
it's not going to be a W for me to say
that there's something mentioned about
Muhammad in Bible or Jesus.
>> Well, for once chat GBT got something
right. So, this means that the Quran is
false because it says that Jesus
mentioned that.
>> I'm actually u watching you for a long
time, but uh I I don't know. But
Christianity, it just seems like too
much complex. When you got the core
basics of the Trinity, it just sounds
too complex. Also, like uh I had doubts.
Yeah, I'm I'm not going to say that I I
don't have any doubts in Islam. I had I
have doubts still in this day. I I have
the Abrahamic faiths, you know, kind of
doubts. Is it even like correct or what?
I I I'm a I'm I'm really a practicing
Muslim by the way but I have doubts. I I
seek uh Christianity but cannot really
trust cannot I don't know it it's it's
whenever I open up YouTube there is like
uh some guys debating you guys debating
some some Christians winning some
Muslims winning it's just like 50/50 out
here it's so confusing.
>> How long have you been a Muslim? I I'm
I'm Muslim my whole life.
>> I've been a Christian my whole life
basically. And what really interests me
about Islam is what it says about Jesus
and the Bible and the prophets. Like it
really talks about them a lot. So that's
what drew me obviously to Islam. Makes a
lot of claims about Jesus that aren't
true. Claims about the prophets that
aren't true. Claims that about the Bible
that the Bible's true and stuff like
that. very important stuff that really
interests me as a Christian. Jesus is my
Lord. He's the Messiah. What he says is
the most important thing ever. And so
when I see that the Quran makes a claim
that Jesus mentioned somebody named
Ahmed to come after him, I've never seen
that before in my life. I've never seen
Jesus ever say this. And all the words
that I read of his in the gospel, he
never said this. He never said anything
like this about Ame coming after him.
And so I'm seeing that the Quran is
making false claims when it comes to
Jesus. Would that matter to you if the
Quran was making false claims about
Jesus and about other prophets? Would
that matter to you?
>> As far as I know that Quran has no
contradictions about anything and it's
perfectly preserved. I don't know if
it's true or not.
>> That's not what I asked you, brother.
Cuz all of that is false. That's just
what they tell you. If the Quran, listen
to my question. If the Quran is making
false claims about the prophets, making
false claims about Jesus, would that
matter to you?
>> Obviously a false thing. Yeah.
>> Right. So when the [clears throat] Quran
says that Jesus said something, saying
something as important as there's
somebody else coming after me who is a
messenger after me. That's important.
That's huge. That's not a little thing
that we can just toss away and brush
off. That's a huge, huge claim that
Jesus, the Lord, the Messiah, said that
there's going to be a messenger coming
after him that we should believe in.
That's huge. That's very important. If
Jesus never said this, then the Quran is
making a false claim about Jesus and
putting lies into his mouth. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. So, uh, what's the Muslim counter
arguments like? How do they counter?
>> The Muslim counterargument would be,
well, we just don't have what Jesus
originally said. They chalk it up to
there's no way for us to know. That's
their counterargument. But unfortunately
for them, we have the gospel. We have
what Jesus said. So, we know what he
said. And he never said this. He never
said that somebody named Ahmed is going
to come after him.
>> So as far as you said that the angel
angel is not here with us anymore. So it
might be the Inil had it written and we
just don't have it anymore.
>> And see and that's impossible because
the Quran says the Christians had the
injil in Muhammad's time. In Muhammad's
time they had the injil they had the
gospel with them. And
>> yeah let me show you the verse. Look,
chapter 7, verse 157. Look at this. Make
sure I get the right. Those who follow
the messenger, the prophet who can
neither read nor write, whom they find
written with them in the Torah and the
angel. Look, the commentator even even
quotes my Bible, even quotes John 14:16.
So the commentator adds and says that
when the when the Quran is talking about
the gospel, it's talking about my Bible,
my New Testament that I have. So the
Quran says that they have the injeil.
It's not gone. It didn't disappear. They
have it. You understand what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So this idea that we don't have the
Injil anymore, it's been lost or gone is
a claim that goes completely against
what the Quran says. Every Muslim that
says we don't have the Injil is going
against the Quran cuz the Quran says we
have the Injil. So look, prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him's time like
there was he said uh in Quran the injil
was obviously always all time there but
the we we always say that obviously some
of some parts of gospels are true some
parts are preserved and some parts are
contradicted and
>> yep and the Quran and that goes against
the Quran too the Quran says the
opposite the Quran watch what watch what
I show you what the Quran says I'm about
to show you everything everything that
you're going say that the da guys say
the da debaters the Muslim debaters that
they say everything they say is opposite
of what the Quran teaches opposite and
I'm not exaggerating it's literally the
opposite verbatim look let me show you
look at this this is chapter 2 85 look
at this it says after this it is you who
kill one another and drive out a party
of you from their homes assist their
enemies against them in sin and
transgression and if they come to you as
captives and you ransom them although
they're expos Exposion was forbidden to
you. This is the important part. Watch
this and listen. Okay. Then do you
believe in part of the scripture and
reject the rest? Then what is the
recompense
of those who do so among you? Except
disgrace in this life of this world. And
on the day of resurrection they'll show
they shall be consigned to the most
grievous torment. And Allah is not
unaware of what you do. So according to
the Quran, the people who pick part of
the scripture they believe in and other
parts they don't believe in, the Quran
says that they're disgraced in this life
and they're going to go to hell in the
next life. That a grievous torment
awaits them. So according to the Quran,
are you allowed to choose what part of
the scripture you believe in? Say this
part's good, but this other part's bad.
Are you allowed to do that according to
the Quran?
>> No. But it it's about the Quran, right?
Only about the Quran. Oh, this is
talking about the Jews and their
scriptures.
>> Oh, so um I don't know.
>> What do you mean you don't know? There's
It's It says right here. It's very
clear. Can you pick and choose what you
believe in the scripture according to
this verse? Can you believe in part of
the scripture and reject other parts of
the scripture? According to this verse,
>> I have to I have to believe in the full
scripture. Right.
>> Exactly. And if you don't believe in the
full scripture, what does Allah say is
going to happen to you? You're gonna be
disgraced in this life and you're going
to go to hell in the next life. You're
gonna have a grievous torment, the most
grievous torment wait for you if you
pick and choose and and don't believe in
all of the scripture. You see, you see
what I'm saying?
>> Okay.
>> So, you can't So, you can't say that you
believe in some of the gospel and reject
other parts of the gospel. You can't say
you believe in some of the Torah and
reject other parts of the Torah. And
same with the Quran. You can't say you
believe in some of the Quran and reject
other parts of the Quran. You can't do
that. Allah hates when people do that.
He hates that. You're going to go to
hell if you do that.
>> If it's like uh uh bro, trust me, if it
was like uh Jesus Christ, the last
prophet and the one God concept, no
trinity, it it would it would make a lot
of sense. But uh the trinity, I just
don't understand the you know.
>> Yeah. Saying that you don't understand a
concept doesn't mean that a concept is
false.
>> Because uh yeah, it might be. But I've
seen a lot of very much Muslims like
really outraging trolling the Trinity
every time. And I also laugh.
>> So what? Who cares?
>> You there's there's there's people that
troll taled. So what
>> people are coming and saying there are
three chickens out there one and
There's people coming saying that
there's 99 chickens because of Allah's
99 attributes and they're saying but all
this is one. So what?
>> Um but those are names.
>> Uh those are names. Those aren't names.
Allah's not all of Allah's attributes
are his names. Like his speech, his
hands, his shin, those are his
attributes. Those aren't names.
>> But um if if it if it was like uh one
one by three is Jesus, one by three is
Holy Spirit, one by three is father.
It's not it's like full one of father is
full god son is full god.
>> This is what this is what I'm not
understanding from you. You're saying
that you don't understand the trinity
therefore it's false but yet you don't
understand but yet you still believe
inhed in Islam.
>> I've never thought like that way. Um
nobody ever come um come come came up to
me like saying uh 99 to one like
>> oh yeah you you believe in you believe
in one god but who's made up of 99
different parts. Rahman U al-lah am al
rabukah yeah there are a lot of names I
don't know about the attributes
>> yeah you don't understand what what
about his hands
>> can you explain his hands to me
>> his hands
>> does not Quran say that he's we cannot
even think we cannot even imagine how is
he look like how how do you know about
his hands
>> well Allah says he has hands in the
Quran it says that he made Adam with his
own hands that's why that's why Adam was
special. Can you metaphor or something
like
>> it's not a metaphor? Because it's what
literally made Adam special. He said,
"Why?" He said to El, "Why did you not
bow down to Adam who I made with my own
hands?" So, he didn't make the angels
with his own hands. He didn't make the
jin with his own hands. But Adam he made
with his own hands, which is what made
him special. So, what are Allah's hands
like? What what are his hands? Are they
actual hands?
>> Allah is is beyond our thinking, right?
I don't know.
>> Right? Do you see that Allah is beyond
our thinking. So you can't comprehend
Allah. You can't comprehend it in the
concept of
>> yet you still accept it. But with the
trinity you need everything explained.
You need everything comprehended or else
you reject it. Do you see the double
standard?
>> Because like how do you know there's
trinity and we say there's one.
>> You're not you're not understanding. Do
you see your double standard with Allah
and you're okay with things not being
comprehendable? With you not
understanding something as simple as his
hands? You don't understand it, yet you
still accept it. But with the Trinity,
you're saying it's too complex. I can't
understand it. Therefore, it's false. Do
you see that double standard? How you're
not being consistent?
>> Yeah, might be.
>> Yeah. So if you're going to say that the
trinity is false because you can't
comprehend it. It's too difficult to
understand then you need to say that
Allah is a false god and that is false
because you can't comprehended or
explain it to me.
>> Like uh if I give you an example like uh
Allah you say the 99 attributes uh the
99 attributes if you just divide them uh
like the 99 parts of Allah it will be
still one. But here, the Trinity, the
problem is you're claiming that Jesus is
fully one. And uh
>> no, you need to make sense of that. You
need to make sense of that. How is it
that you have a God that's made up of 99
parts and he's supposed to be the one
true God, but he's comp he's a composite
being like you and I. He's made up of
parts. So without the parts, Allah is
not Allah. He's like he's like a tree. A
tree is made up of different parts that
make up a tree. These different
attributes that make up the tree. You
need the wood, you need the leaf, you
know, you need all these different
>> He's God. So,
>> so what?
>> He's God. So, obviously he's he's going
to have attributes like he's merciful,
he's powerful, the it's like trees,
what's the problem?
>> But these part Oh, he's like trees. So,
so when you say that we can't imagine
Allah and he's nothing like creation,
but yet he is just like his creation in
that he's made up of parts. That's
confusing to me. That sounds
contradictory.
>> Okay. So, um, how do you explain the
trinity? Actually,
>> do you see what you're doing?
>> Yeah, it might be a double standard. I I
don't know.
>> Yeah, it might be a double standard.
See, this this is the thing. Like I
said, if you can't be honest and see the
double standard that you have in Islam,
there's no point in me explaining the
trinity to you. Me breaking down the
trinity to you, it's it's worthless.
Because for you in Christianity, you
need everything explained to the tea.
Everything has to have an explanation
when it comes to God's nature in
Christianity. But in Islam, you're okay
with things not being comprehendable,
things not making sense, things not
being totally consistent. You're okay
with
>> I was born with it. You have to
understand I lived my whole life with
it.
>> So who cares about that? Do you care
about truth? the Hindu peoples in India
well they obviously doesn't their faith
will break in us like obviously you know
that's the question I don't care about
that do you care do you care about truth
>> truth yeah obviously but there are like
4,000 religions man
>> yeah so it doesn't matter how you were
born if you grow up and you realize that
what you believed in growing up is false
and inconsistent drop it you know what
I'm saying drop it Yeah,
>> be honest. Go where the that go be
honest and go where the evidence leads.
If if if you're going to reject a
position based on you not being able to
comprehend it or it's seemingly not
making sense to you, then have that same
energy for everything. Don't just have
that energy for Christianity, but when
it comes to Islam, you just let
everything go. You don't you don't
critically think about it. You you you
let the inconsistencies just go. the
concept of Allah and how he his hands
and his attributes how inconsistent that
is and incomprehensible that is but you
still accept it no have the same energy
drop it reject it like you do
Christianity so actually what happened
to me uh maybe it was like almost a week
ago I I had a dream about Jesus so I'm
not going to make it like super
cherry-picking I I uh in my dreams I saw
something like Jesus And after that I
was amazed uh in the morning but at the
same time I had a thinking like oh
Christianity uh there's a picture of
Jesus maybe that's what I saw you know
what you do in daily life activities you
you see your family members in your
dreams you see your friends in your
dreams just like that you there was a
picture of a of a long uh long-haired
bearded Jesus. That's what I saw in my
dreams. That might be just a
coincidence. Uh that that's I I I don't
know if if it was like Jesus or just uh
the human psychology of dream.
>> What amazed you about the dream?
>> I I I saw uh you know just just like uh
you see Jesus in anywhere like the art
the the picture of Jesus the bearded
guy. What? Bearded white guy in in white
clothes.
>> What What amazed you? You said that when
you saw him, you were amazed. What What
amazed you?
>> Amazed. There was just like it I was
maybe there was lights everywhere and
Jesus and it was shocking. I I was I
woke up right right at right at the bat.
I don't know it was a what what what was
that? And I'm I'm actually confused. I
I've never been to like Christianity so
much after uh before that. After that, I
really uh searched a lot of debates or
something like that. I'm not quite sure
what was that.
>> Well, there's a lot of people that have
had similar experiences to you. Have you
heard of of other people mentioning that
they've had dreams of Jesus, seeing
Jesus as Muslims?
>> I don't know.
>> You should look into that. Um uh I've
had a lot of people come on this channel
and talk about how they have seen Jesus
um as Muslims as devout Muslims and
they've had a dream of Jesus or had a
vision of Jesus. If you go on YouTube
and you put in Muslims who have had
dreams of Jesus or seen Jesus or even
Jews, Orthodox Jews as well, um there's
a lot of testimonies out there that's
like that and it amazed them. It shocked
them. Some of them it made them a little
nervous, a little scared because they're
like, "What is this? Why am I seeing
Jesus? Why do I know that it is him?"
Like, notice how in a lot of these
experiences, even in yours, you knew it
was Jesus. You never seen Jesus before.
You don't know who Jesus. You never seen
him physically. But in every one of
these experiences, everybody always
knows that it's Jesus who they saw, who
they experienced, and then and then they
end up coming to the truth and reading
the gospel and seeing who Jesus truly
is, not this false facade that, you
know, Islam will put up in the Quran,
this fake Jesus or in Mormonism, but the
true Jesus of the gospel, the true
living son of God who came in the flesh,
died for your sins, rose again on the
third day. And it seems like if you're
being honest, I don't know, only God
knows if you're being honest. But if
you're telling the truth about what
you're saying, it looks like God is
pulling on you as well and trying to
bring you to the truth, which is putting
you in a position to question and seek
and ask things and, you know, become
skeptical, which is okay. But Jesus says
this. He says in John chapter 14, he
says something very, very interesting.
He says, I'm sorry, John chapter 10, he
says, "My sheep hear my voice. I know
them and they follow me." That's what he
says. It's very interesting. My sheep
hear my voice. I know them and they
follow me. They know me in return.
That's how intimate Jesus is. Especially
with those of us who grew up Muslim,
grew up atheist, grew up orthodox Jew,
grew up rejecting him. But still, he
comes to us and calls us and you're able
to recognize him, you know. So, it's
something to think about. It's something
to think about. Um, this looks like you
might be one of his sheep that he's
calling. Have you ever read the gospel
before?
>> Nope. Never.
>> You never read the gospel, man.
>> All in my like life, I've heard that,
you know, gospels, the Bible is false,
but I never read it. Uh,
>> you never read it yourself?
>> Yeah. Yeah. All all all I know about
gospels like in Instagram memes where
the da guys um saying uh refuting
arguments and I've never like explored
the Christian side of gospels like I
I've I've discovered the Muslim sides of
refuting gospels.
>> Man, you got to you got to you got to
look at it yourself, man. You got to
read the gospel for yourself. I want to
show you something, man. I want to show
you um let me just show you a few things
with Jesus in the gospel. I'm going to
show you how he reveals himself. How he
reveals himself. Watch this. So, this
will be in Mark. This will be in Mark
chapter 6. This is Mark chapter 6 over
here on the right. Okay. Oh, I already
had it up. I already had it up on the
left. So, we got Mark chapter 6. And uh
there's another one that I want to go
to, too. Let's see here. Watch this. So,
it says we're going to read uh over here
on the left screen. Okay. On the right
scale. Where's the Where's the parallel
passage of Matthew, guys? Where's the
parallel passage of Matthew where Jesus
walks on water? Quickly now, so I can
show them this. Thank you. Matthew 14.
Matthew 14
27 to 33. Okay. Let's start a little
earlier. 24. Start a little earlier than
that. Okay. All right. So, watch this.
You still with me?
>> Yeah, I'm here.
>> Okay. So, this is Mark. We got Mark on
the left. We got Matthew on the right.
Okay. We're going to meet read Mark
first. Okay. So it says immediately he
made his disciples get into the boat and
go before him to the other side to
Bethida when he dismissed the crowd. And
after he had taken the taken leave of
them, he went up on the mountain to
pray. And when evening came, the boat
was out on the sea and he was alone on
the land. And he saw that they were
making headway painfully for the wind
was against them. So the disciples are
on the sea. They're in the boat, but the
winds are raging. About the fourth watch
of the night, he came to them walking on
the sea. He meant to pass them by. But
when they saw him walking on the sea,
they thought it was a ghost and cried
out, for they and cried out, for they
all saw him and were terrified. But
immediately he spoke to them and said,
"Take heart. It is I. Do not be afraid."
And he got into the boat with them, and
the wind ceased. And they were utterly
astounded for they did not understand
about the loaves but their hearts were
hardened. And I watched the rendition in
Matthew as well. Same thing. Okay, we're
going to read over here starting at
verse 26. But when the disciples saw him
walking on the sea, they were terrified
and said, "It is a ghost." Matthew gives
a little bit more detail. And they cried
out in fear. But immediately Jesus spoke
to them, saying, "Take heart. It is I.
Do not be afraid." Now watch what Peter
does. And Peter answered him,"Lord,
if it is you, command me to come to you
on the water." And he said, "Come."
[clears throat] So Peter got out of the
boat and walked on the water and came to
Jesus. But when he saw the wind, he was
afraid and beginning to sink, he cried
out, "Lord, save me." Jesus immediately
reached out his hand and took hold of
him, saying to him, "Oh, you of little
faith, why do you doubt?" And when they
got into the boat, the wind ceased, and
those in the boat worshiped him, saying,
"Truly, you are the son of God." Let me
ask you this. Does this look like a mere
man, a mere prophet who could just walk
on water and then give somebody else the
ability to walk on water?
>> Walk on water. Hear the the term son of
God. And also these things like yeah it
might something look like some divine
thing
>> but you know hazam
the king Solomon also had uh he he could
talk to he could do supernatural things
it's it's not only Jesus right but it's
only God who commands the seas who
commands the waters who commands the
winds and not only that brother but look
you have Jesus Jesus giving Peter the
ability to walk on water too. Can a can
a can a mere prophet give another person
mira miraculous ability?
>> No.
>> Nope. Only God can. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So Jesus is demonstrating and revealing
himself as being God in the flesh even
here by commanding the winds and the and
the seas, commanding the waves of the
water while they're raging and rushing.
He's the one who has command over this.
Not only that, but he's able to cause
Peter to walk on water as well. And
notice what Peter, Peter had enough
faith. He said, he said, "Lord, if it's
you, command me to come to you on the
water." So Peter also has this idea that
he's the divine son of God who has
command over the natural elements who
can also cause him to miraculously walk
on water.
>> Okay? So, two gospels promote that,
right?
>> Yep. Uh, it's in Luke as well, I
believe. Um, at least Matthew Matthew
and Mark. I'm I'm not sure if it's in
Luke, but yeah, Matthew and Mark. And
then there's something uh there's
something interesting because all of
this reflects the Psalms, the Old
Testament, the Zabore. It's not in Luke.
Okay. It's not in Luke. Okay. So, just
Yeah. Matthew and Mark. Now, watch this.
So, this is Psalm 107. This is Psalm 107
is talking about God. Oh, give thanks to
the Lord for he is good. for his
steadfast love endures forever. It's
talking about it's a prayer and an ad
admiration to God. Watch what this psalm
says. It says, "So he borrowed their
hearts down with hard labor. They fell
down with none to help. They cried out
to the Lord in their trouble and he
delivered them from their distress. He
brought them out of of darkness and the
shadow of death and burst their bonds
apart." Now watch as it keeps going. We
get over here. It says uh it says uh
they cried to the Lord in their trouble
and he delivered them from their
distress. He sent out his word and he
healed them and delivered them from
their destruction. Let them thank the
Lord for his steadfastness for his
wondrous works to the children of man.
And let them offer sacrifices of
thanksgiving and tell of his deeds and
songs of joy. Now, I'm building this up
because I'm about to show you how this
connects to Jesus walking on water and
saving them with the raging winds and
stuff. I'm about to show you this. So,
watch. Um, [clears throat]
let's see here. Oh, here it is. It says,
"They mounted up to heaven. They went
down to the depths." Right? Talking
about the seas. They went out to the
depths to the seas. Their courage melted
away in their evil plight. They reeled
and staggered like drunken men and they
were at their wits end. They were
afraid. They were scared. They were
losing their minds. They were freaking
out. Then they cried to the Lord in
their trouble, and he delivered them
from their distress. He made the storm
be still, and the waves of the sea were
hushed. Then they were glad that the
waters were quiet, and he brought them
to their desired haven. Let them thank
the Lord for his steadfast love, for his
wondrous works to the children of men.
Does this sound familiar? God saving
>> children of men. God saving people who
are stranded at the sea
>> where their waves in the waters are
crashing, their boat is rocking, they're
freaking out and they cry out to the
Lord to save them and he comes and saves
them and as a result they thank they
thank him. This is exactly
>> a prophecy or something.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> So the psalm is like the zabur of daisam
right?
>> That's right. That's right. Oh. So, so
doesn't zabur also mentions prophet
Muhammad?
>> No, it doesn't mention Muhammad anyway.
There's nothing in the Bible.
>> In Zabur, the the says soam
believed that Jesus is God. Right.
>> That's right. And you see how this is
this is how the Bible is is connected
like this. The scripture is connected
like this. You have David in the Psalms
writing in the Psalms or Let me see if
this is actually David. Yeah. So, you
have David in the Psalms writing about
how God saves the people who are working
out on the sea, out in the depths, um,
fighting the waves in the sea. They're
freaking out. They're scared out of
their minds, and they cry out to the
Lord, and the Lord comes and delivers
them, calms the sea, quiets the storm,
quiets the waves, and takes them and
helps them get to their destination. And
as a result, they thank him just like
what we see here in over here. In
Matthew, it says, "And those in the boat
worshiped him, saying, truly you are the
son of God."
>> Okay. So, yeah, it it it looks kind of
miraculous.
>> Yep. So, this isn't something that
Christians are making up that Jesus is
God in human form, that he's God in the
flesh. No, this is what the scriptures
teach. And Jesus is he he's doing this
on purpose. He didn't this wasn't just
some random miracle he decided to do.
No, this is him choosing in a way to
reveal himself to his disciples as the
divine son of God to all of them. This
is one of the ways and he does it in a
way that Yahweh reveals himself and
works on behalf of the children of men
and he and how he works the miracles,
calms the storms, relaxes the waves,
help them get to their destination and
they thank them as a result. This is how
this is how intertwined the Bible is,
>> how connected it is. So,
>> so with this man, I I I would encourage
you, read the gospel, bro. Open the
gospel and learn about the true Jesus.
Learn about the real Jesus, what he did,
what he taught, what he requires of us,
and what he did for you, what he did for
you and me.
>> Obviously. Okay. So, I'm going to
obviously learn about Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> Obviously, I believe him as a prophet
till now, but I don't know about
divinity. Yeah, there's a lot of things
going on here and um yeah, you know,
when you're Muslim, uh you feel like uh
the the pressure is so much
>> Yeah.
>> We got the community going on.
>> Yeah. It's [clears throat] funny. Jes
Jesus actually speaks to that too cuz
you're right. You got a lot of pressure.
You got a lot of, you know, as Muslims,
especially with this type of thing, you
got a lot of a lot of pressure, a lot of
um a big burden, you know, to keep your
aid, to keep your your dean, um to not
question, brings a lot of pressure. This
is what Jesus says, bro, in light of
this. Let me just show you. This is
Matthew chapter uh Matthew chapter uh
this is Matthew chapter uh 11. Matthew
chapter 11. Watch what Jesus says when
it comes to those who have a lot to
carry, have a lot of burden, have a lot
of pressure. Watch what he says, man. He
speak I'm telling you in the gospel,
Jesus speaks right to our situation
every single time. He speaks right to
us. These are the divine words of the
Lord. So Jesus says, he says, "All
things have been handed over to me by my
father and no one knows the son except
the father and no one knows the father
except the son. and whom and anyone whom
the son chooses to reveal him. Now watch
what he says. Come to me all who labor
and are heavy laden. All of you who have
the extra pressures, who have the heavy
burdens, he says come to me those of you
with heavy burdens with pressure. And
what does he say? He says, "And I will
give you rest." He says, "Take my yoke
upon you. Let's switch. You give me your
yoke, I'll give you mine. You give me
your heavy burdens, I'll give you my
light burden. Watch what he says. Take
my yoke upon you and learn from me. For
I am gentle and lowly in heart and you
will find rest for your souls. For my
yoke is easy and my burden is light.
Jesus says, "Let's trade. You feel the
pressures, give them to me. You feel the
he you're heavy laden, heavy labor. Give
that all to me and I will give you my
burden. My yoke because my yoke is easy.
My burden is not heavy. It's very light.
Easy. My burden brings rest for you. Not
pressure, not sweat, but it brings an
ease to you. You can rest in me is what
Jesus says. Even as a Muslim, I'm
telling you, he's calling. That's what
I'm saying, man. He speaks directly to
you. You have the pressure of keeping
the dean, following the dean, not
questioning. No. Jesus says, "Give it
all to me. All your questions, all your
cares, all your skepticism, bring it to
me. Lay it on me, for I'm gentle and
humble. Learn from me." You'll never
find anything like this in the Quran.
You'll never find Allah saying, "Bring
me your burden and I'll give you mine.
I'll give you my burden as light. I'll
give you rest for your soul." You'll
never see anything in the Quran saying
this. Jesus guarantees this for you.
>> Okay? [clears throat] So, yeah,
>> this is the gospel, bro. This is this is
the true Jesus. This is who he is. This
is who you're missing out on. This is
the one you saw in your dream and who's
pulling on you. This is the one. You got
to get to know him, bro.
>> Okay.
>> So, what will happen to all my beliefs?
All all all the salah, all the salom,
all the zakat, all the tawa, all the
hajj. What What will happen to my ram,
bro? All these years,
>> all of that, all of that fell on deaf
ears because you're giving salat and
performing these works to a false god,
to a god who has given you a false Jesus
and a false gospel message contrary to
the message that the true god, the true
Jesus revealed. So all those times you
went to the majid, all those salat that
you prayed, um I don't know if you've
ever been to the cabba and did the hajj,
but every Ramadan that you fasted and
feasted, all of that, all of that
matters not. None of that makes you
righteous. None of that counts for for
the Lord. The only thing that counts is
your faith in the true God and the work
that he did for you. There's nothing
that you could do that could be worthy
of God's mercy and righteousness and
grace. He did the work for you. And
that's what the gospel message is. The
gospel message is that you are a sinner.
You sinned against God. And God is holy
and just and you deserve hellfire. You
deserve his punishment. But he's loving
at the same time. So what he does is he
comes in human form and he takes on the
punishment on your behalf. The
punishment that you deserve. He takes it
on himself. He does the work for you
because you couldn't do it. He does the
work for you and offers you a free way
in through your faith in him. Believe in
what he did for you. Believe in him as
your Lord and his righteousness is put
on you. You are not righteous yourself.
Nothing you are, nothing you do. The
only righteousness we have is the
righteousness we have in Christ because
he's the holy and righteous one who is
pure and purified us by his blood and
his work and his sacrifice. That's the
gospel.
>> I hope u the message will be more more
and more clear to you uh clear to me
obviously pray for me. I don't know what
will happen
>> and and you know uh where I'm living
right now the father dan you know is
going on I have to go for the prayer and
thanks for your time thanks uh again
>> this was really a good time I learned a
lot of things I'll obviously research
and is there any book you can suggest me
>> Matthew
>> okay gospel of Matthew okay so yeah I'm
going to leave right now okay
>> all right take care of yourself man have
a good rest of your day we'll be praying
for you man. And don't be a stranger. If
you got questions and concerns or
whatever, come back. I'll let you up. We
can talk. Okay.
>> Obviously. Okay. Thank you.
>> Take care, man. All right. That was a
awesome guest. I pray that he was
sincere in everything that he was
saying. And I pray that uh that he was
true to himself and that um that God
does a work in him. That God grows that
seed that was planted. that God grows
that seed that was planted.